spencer turnbull relishing this
opportunity against
the all-star game mvp of a year ago
shane bieber
runner goes pitches a strike and ramirez
has the bag stolen
he came out of there we heard somebody
say he's going the first baseman and he
took off but romine really did not have
a chance
3-2 swinging to miss 97 mile an hour
fastball
right by carlos santana that was
electric
and bieber off to a terrific start 3-0
on 163 earned run average
little topper right back to beaver take
your time
oh nice play by santana bailed him out
here's the two one hammers it to left
that ball
is off the wall played by stewart
quickly gets it in
santana digging for two and he is
out nice play by kristen stewart
played the carom well threw a bullet to
jonathan scope
no score in the second and kristen
stewart with good pop at the plate
oh he went too far that's going to be a
strikeout
swings and misses chase the slider down
and away
bieber gets his second strikeout now
cesar hernandez
oh look at this
he didn't get it in time and how about
that cesar hernandez
with a bunch single so the inning is set
up now
for the tribe base is loaded nobody out
jose ramirez
is the batter yanked
deep right and it's over the head of
maven it goes to the wall
scoring as leone scoring is mercado
stopping at third as hernandez it's a
two-run double for jose ramirez
and the indians are off and running here
in the third santana has walked to
reload the bases as front middle reyes
digs in on the ground to short good room
to scope
the turn in time tigers get the double
play they need
but now let's see what bieber comes out
and does after they do get him two runs
austin roman said i waited 56 minutes
for that normally you can't take a
fastball for strike three but bieber
gets a lot of them because his breaking
ball is so good
like that curveball four consecutive
punch outs for bieber
at its own two
that time he called him out on a
fastball shane bieber has
struck out the last five tigers that
have made an out
here is miguel cabrera look at there's
i mean that was perfect those last two
pitches
heater up and in and let's go slide her
down and away
i i mean i totally agree and there you
go the he is on fire man
look at the hitters are talking to
themselves seven strikeouts
so here we go full count will it be
strikeout number eight
eight out of nine for shane bieber la
machine
on display there he goes
see he didn't worry about him and he
gets his second stolen base of the night
the count runs full three and two on
carlos santana
smokes it left center that's a gapper
that'll get down and that's gonna play
jose ramirez
and the indians lead is three to nothing
and gives santana
his second double and just his fourth
run batted in on the year and
51 strikeouts now on the year
he has been on some kind of roll in the
last three innings
strong on it missy struck him out now
the 2-2 to reyes here it comes
strong boy was that a good breaking ball
his 10th strikeout of the night shane
bieber comes back
out 85 pitches on the night tried to
hold up but he went around and strikes
him out
11th strikeout of the night for shane
bieber
ground ball to short glendor to her end
is on the first it's
an inning ending double play bieber
still has a shutout
through seven
this one stays in play nice diving play
made by candelario and a nice toss to
ronnie garcia
to get lindor doesn't matter if he's
playing third or first
jamer candelario laying out to make
another dynamite defensive play
indians on top three nothing bottom of
the ninth inning brad hand will come on
for
the indians here's jacoby jones and he's
got a flare for the dramatic
now the 2-2 to left field
that ball is going to drop it's a fair
ball
one run is home scope trots into third
jacoby jones
delivers in a clutch situation cameron
maven
oh for three tonight
right back to brad hand this will do it
the lefty flips to first and the indians
win again that's 19 in a row over the
tigers